Many people take their right to privacy for granted.
But most don't realize that this right doesn't extend to the...
... place where they spend most of their waking hours: their workplace.
Privacy is one of the most violated principles.
People do realize monitoring goes on,...
...but most individuals are unaware of how pervasive the lack of privacy is.
Monitoring employees electronically and in other ways is a growing part of the way companies do business.
Some 76% of employers monitor workers' Web connections,...
... while 50% store and monitor employees' computer files.
Employers monitor for three main reasons: legal liability issues,...
...employee productivity, and security breaches.
For example, e-mail creates a written business record,...
...and employers are becoming increasingly aware that...
... e-mail and Internet activity is the electronic equivalent of DNA evidence.
More than half of all employers block unauthorized phone numbers,...
...and monitor the amount of time spent on the phone and the numbers dialed.
More than 80% of the employers who monitor these activities...
...notify employees about what they are doing.
Employers use video surveillance in an effort to prevent theft,...
...violence and sabotage.
Again more than half of all employers use video monitoring.
Of those, 85% notify workers of the practice.
However, video surveillance cameras may be installed in many areas of the workplace,...
...including locker rooms, leading to a lack of privacy.
We may not live in Orwell's 1984, but big brother is watching.